The FDA has authorized the Pfizer Bion tech
coronavirus vaccine. They did it on Friday night.
Now, it came under a cloud of allegations that
either Trump or his chief of staff, Mark Meadows,
or someone called the FDA director, Steven Hahn,
and said approve this today. And when Steven Hahn
was interviewed about that over the weekend, he
didn't deny it. He just insisted everything was
done based on the science. And to me, that's
a pretty clear nondenial. But the point is,
we now have an approved vaccine. The same
vaccine has been approved in the U.K.
It has been approved in Canada, and now it
has been approved here in the United States.
Vaccination starts today, as far as we
know, with high risk health care workers
believed to be getting top priority in all 50
states. Ultimately, states decide how to allocate
and prioritize the tranches of doses that they
will be receiving. We have three million doses
already fanning out across the country via
logistics and shipping companies over the weekend.
One hundred and forty five different
sites will be receiving the vaccine today.
Another four hundred sites tomorrow, another sixty
something on Wednesday. Now, there is not nearly
enough supply. Even if now we say we're just doing
medical workers, we don't yet have the supply to
inoculate every doctor, nurse, hospital, security
guard, receptionist, phlebotomist, other workers
who risk being exposed every single
day. We just don't have enough doses yet
because the vaccines can cause side effects
like fevers and aches for a day or two.
Hospitals also can't even if they had all the
doses, they can't give it to everybody at once
because everybody might be out sick the next day.
Obviously, it's only a fraction that actually get
the side effects, but you have to stagger it
in order to avoid even the possibility of that.
So this is going to be a process. Residents of
nursing homes who have been disproportionately
suffering the death by coronavirus
are also expected to be top priority.
And again, this is all based on expected shipping.
We're expecting to see some nursing home residents
start to be vaccinated next week. New York's
first coronavirus vaccines have arrived and we're
expecting vaccinations today at Long Island Jewish
Medical Center and maybe even a couple of other
locations. Most people's eligibility based
on prioritization is likely to put them
sometime around spring for being able to get
a vaccine. The New York Times reported that
the administration had a plan to vaccinate all
of its own staff, including people that work
around Trump, even though these first doses
are supposed to go to health care workers.
And apparently there was not good reaction to
that. Donald Trump canceling that by Twitter
yesterday, saying, quote, People working in
the White House should receive the vaccine
somewhat later in the program, unless specifically
necessary. I have asked that this adjustment be
made. I am not scheduled to take the vaccine, but
look forward to doing so at the appropriate time.
Still, we are going to have to deal with vaccine
hesitancy issues among some, and that's raising
questions about whether all available doses will
even be requested once we get my expectation is
now, with the doses going to health care workers
and still not having enough for all of them,
every dose will be spoken for. For now in the
nursing home phase, I believe every dose will
be spoken for once we get a second approved
vaccine. Moderna more than likely and we see
the next layer, which is likely going to be the
old folks if you don't have the demand that you
expect. And as of right now, sixty percent
of the country plans to get the vaccine, 40
percent of the country does not. You could have a
situation where even these early batches of doses
don't get swept up. And in that case,
there's going to be some real questions. Now,
you know, the the idea would be that over time,
as you start to see, oh, my kids school requires
that parents to be vaccinated, I don't know if
that's possible or eventually if the vaccines
are open for kids, the kid to be vaccinated or
if I want to fly with this airline, I have to
be vaccinated. I want to go to a sporting event.
I have to be vaccinated. That will probably push
the number of people wanting the vaccine up from
sixty. They will call it a mandatory vaccination.
Of course it won't be. It will be if you want to
partake in a certain service or business. Then you
have to choose to go and get a vaccine. It's up
to you ultimately, but we could have a situation
where because of under use of the vaccines, due to
lack of interest, you're going to have a situation
where people may well be able to jump the line.
And what I mean by that is if hospitals are giving
the vaccines to their workers, they know who
qualifies. If nursing homes or homes are giving
vaccines to their residents, they know these are
our residents. Once you get beyond that, from what
I've been reading, CVS and Walgreens aren't
going to check. Do you really have diabetes?
Is that do you actually qualify right now under
the you have to have one or two comorbidities.
And so the opportunity to jump the line is
likely to be a real thing. Now, at the same time,
if not everybody wants the vaccine, you may have
doses left over. And I don't know how it's going
to be chaotic to some degree. My approach is going
to be at no point will I act in a way where I am
taking a vaccine away from someone who's higher
priority than me, who wants it. If it becomes
clear that the doses are not actually being
swept up by the people who are next on the list,
and there's an announcement of come and get
one or pay a hundred bucks and come and get
one because we have doses unclaimed that will go
bad if somebody doesn't get vaccinated. I would
absolutely do that. But I have no interest in
jumping the line if it's going to actually take a
vaccine away from someone who is up next in terms
of the vaccination protocol, that's my mindset.
And we're going to take it a week at a time
and track the number of people who have been
vaccinated, remembering that you are not
considered sort of a maximum inoculation
until seven days after dose number two.
Very, very important to remember that.
Let me know where your head is on
vaccination. I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and continue with more
right after The David Pakman
Show at David Pakman Dotcom.